In the age of
multiculturalism, we're assured that
every culture should be celebrated
except our own. All religious practices
should be honored except our own. No
one's values should be condemned except
our own. For some reason, this self-
flagagillating nonsense is enjoyable for
lots of people who've gone through the
Western education system. But it only
works if you're completely out of touch
with history and reality. Let's see why.
CBS News reports ancient altar found in
Guatemala jungle apparently used for
sacrifices, especially of children.
Archaeologists say an altar from the
Teotiwakan culture at the prehispanic
heart of what became Mexico was
discovered in Teal National Park in
Guatemala, the center of Mayan culture,
demonstrating the interaction between
the two societies. Guatemala's culture
and sports ministry announced this week
the enormous citystate of Teal whose
towering temples still stand in the
jungle battled for centuries with the
Connell dynasty for dominance of the
Maya world. So Teayot Tiwakan was a city
in what's now Mexico, but they found a
Teayotiwakan altar in Guatemala, which
means there was some cultural sharing
going on. The problem is that what was
being shared was child
sacrifice. Far to the north in Mexico,
just outside present-day Mexico City,
Teot Tiwakan, the city of the gods, or
the place where men become gods, is best
known for its twin temples of the sun
and moon. It was actually a large city
that housed over a 100,000 inhabitants
and covered around 8 square miles. The
still mysterious city was one of the
largest in the world at its peak between
100 BC and AD 750, but it was abandoned
before the rise of the Aztecs in the
14th century. Lorena Pice, the
archaeologist who led the discovery,
said that the Teotiwakan altar was
believed to have been used for
sacrifices, especially of
children. Why would they sacrifice their
children? And why did this practice
spring up in so many different parts of
the ancient
world? The remains of three children not
older than four years were found on
three sides of the altar. Pise told the
Associated Press. The Teayotiwakan were
traders who traveled all over the
country. Guatemala. Pi said the
Teotiwakan residential complexes were
houses with rooms and in the center
altars. That's what the residence that
was found is like with an altar with the
figure representing the storm
goddess. Sounds like they were
sacrificing their children to appease
the storm goddess.
Maria Balen Menddees, an archaeologist
who was not involved with the project,
said the discovery confirms that there
has been an interconnection between both
cultures and what their relationships
with their gods and celestial bodies was
like. We see how the issue of sacrifice
exists in both cultures. It was a
practice. It's not that they were
violent. It was their way of connecting
with the celestial bodies. She said they
connected with the celestial bodies and
appeased the storm goddess through human
sacrifice, especially child sacrifice.
So, how did people in the Americas come
up with the same idea, child sacrifice,
as people in the ancient near east and
in other parts of the world? And why
does it seem so strange to us now when
it was apparently pretty normal back
then? I'll answer those questions after
a brief message about this video's
sponsor. Ladies and gentlemen, don't
sacrifice your children. Instead, buy
your children an arts box, which will
connect them with the Bible and
ultimately help them understand the
message that put an end to child
sacrifice. More on that message in a
moment. We partnered with Artzabox, a
company that gathers items from Jewish
and Christian small businesses and
charities in Jerusalem and Nazareth and
Bethlehem and other locations and ships
them to you in a box. You get dishes,
decorations, pendants, candy, Israeli
spices, all kinds of things along with a
booklet that tells you about the people
who provide them, teaches you some basic
Hebrew, and explains how the items are
connected to the theme. Artza boxes are
fun to open with your family and they
make great gifts. Your kids will love
them way more than being sacrificed.
There's a new one every 3 months. It's
like Christmas four times a year. So,
sign up to get your first Artza box. The
link is in the description. Use the
promo code dizzle to get a discount and
to let them know who sent you. Now, back
to our topic, child sacrifice.
Why did various cultures in completely
different parts of the ancient world get
the same idea about offering their
children to their gods? Well, in the
ancient world, your devotion to your god
was measured by the value of the
sacrifice you brought to the altar.
People demonstrated their love for their
god by offering what was most valuable
to them. What's the most valuable
sacrifice people could bring to the
altar? their children. In the ancient
land of Canaan, for instance, priests of
the god Malik would heat up a bronze
statue of Malik until it was glowing,
and the devout would place their
children into its fiery arms where their
children would
burn. Then came Abraham.
One of the most famous stories in the
Old Testament is the story of God
commanding Abraham to sacrifice his son
Isaac. In Genesis 22, God tells Abraham
to sacrifice Isaac. So Abraham takes
Isaac to a mountain, but Isaac doesn't
know what his dad's about to do. As
they're walking, Isaac asks his father
Abraham, "Where's the lamb for the burnt
offering?"
Abraham answers, "God himself will
provide the lamb for the burnt
offering." Abraham ties up his son and
puts him on a pile of wood and is ready
to kill him. But God stops him and tells
him not to hurt Isaac. Then Abraham
looks and sees a ram caught by its horns
and Abraham offers the ram as a
sacrifice. Critics of the Bible point to
this and say how barbaric that God would
tell Abraham to do that and that Abraham
would be willing to sacrifice his son.
But I think they're missing the point.
Abraham was surrounded by people who
were convinced that the greatest thing
they could do was sacrifice their
children to their God. Abraham was ready
to do it, but God told him to stop.
The takeaway message of the story of
Abraham and Isaac for the surrounding
culture was this. Abraham is just as
devout as any of you. He's the sort of
person who's willing to do whatever his
God
commands. The difference between you and
Abraham is that Abraham's God doesn't
want him to sacrifice his son. Abraham's
God stops him from sacrificing his son.
Abraham's God provides his own
sacrifice. So in various ancient
cultures, you would demonstrate your
love for your God by sacrificing what
was most precious and valuable to you.
The message of the Bible is that you
don't sacrifice your way to God. God
provides his own sacrifice and
demonstrates his love by sacrificing his
way to
you. This message changed the world. And
as people in the 21st century turn away
from the god who provides his own
sacrifice, what happens? They return to
the paganism of child sacrifice,
demonstrating their devotion to their
new gods by offering up their
children. Think about the grooming gangs
in the UK. Tens of thousands of young
girls were horribly abused and police
and social workers and prosecutors knew
it was happening.
Why did they let it
happen? To demonstrate their devotion to
tolerance, their new god. If you're a
Hollywood A-listister, you can't show up
to the awards show with your son or
daughter unless your son or daughter has
had some body parts
removed. What is everyone
doing? They're sacrificing their
children to appease their new
gods. But here's an idea.
Let's stick with the God who provides
his own
sacrifice. For God so loved the world
that he gave his one and only son that
whoever believes in him shall not perish
but have eternal life. For God did not
send his son into the world to condemn
the world but to save the world through
him.
[Music]